[Música]
hola desde montreal provincia de québec
eba un saludo a todos nuestros oyentes e
internautas que nos siguen en este
momento por medio de facebook de youtube
y también a los que nos siguen a través
de nuestro sitio web eres hitler punto
sea es un placer estar con ustedes
nuevamente después de un mes de ausencia
prácticamente hola como estan leonardo
ausencias es invertido se sintió mucho
nosotros nos como que nos faltaba pues
si si los juegos ya estos también es
porque hemos recibido mensajes de gente
diciendo es donde puede escuchar la
emisión de la semana pasada no la hubo
claro hay que decir estamos en acá en
vacaciones el equivalente en el cono sur
o más al sur digamos de méxico o américa
central para abajo
son las vacaciones en enero febrero acá
el equivalente es julio agosto lo cual
no significa que las actividades se
detengan sobre todo allá pensamos por
ejemplo que hay elecciones ahora que se
vienen en octubre en bolivia en uruguay
en argentina entonces allá está full
toda la gente la campaña las vacaciones
un receso escolar
son dos semanas de vacaciones entonces
la vida como que continúa fuerte allá yo
creo que hay que explicarle a la gente
también que el verano es muy corto en
canadá
claro corto en relación al invierno que
es muy largo y frío
entonces acá julio agosto la gente
desaparece se se va de festejos los
festivales corto pero torrico exacto sí
ya que también bueno no hay que
olvidarse que también en canadá y
elecciones estén en octubre el mismo
aunque todavía no se ve esa
efervescencia que se puede ver en otros
países
es ciencia esencia va a tardar un
poquito en llegar acá pero bueno no es
exactamente lo mismo que en américa del
sur donde las campañas ocupan meses y
meses calles y calles edificios y
edificios pancartas y pancartas a cada
cosa es un poco más caro exacto ahora
sólo para hablar cortito de elecciones
vos hiciste algo louis hace esta semana
justamente en referencia a las
elecciones en uruguay donde hubo una
queja de cancillería del canciller de
uruguay no y qué pasó ahí porque se
quejó bueno ha habido una denuncia de
parte de las autoridades uruguayas de
una presunta interferencia de eeuu en el
proceso electoral uruguayo además
uruguay está preparando una reforma de
su ley de seguridad
y días pasados como acostumbra ser
frecuente el día del mes pasado
bueno como acostumbra ser frecuentemente
eeuu calificó a uruguay como lo ha hecho
con tantos otros países como un país no
seguro para sus turistas entonces
recomendó a sus ciudadanos que están
desesperados por viajar a uruguay
al viajar a eeuu es importante las
fechas porque el fin de semana después
en un gesto que comentamos y que yo te
dije que me llamaba mucho la atención y
que aplaudía uruguay contexto lanzando
una recomendación a todos sus ciudadanos
uruguayos de que no viaje en eeuu si no
es absolutamente necesario y con
elementos mucho más contundentes porque
acababan de ocurrir el deseo señalas el
día el día viernes acababan de ocurrir
muy pocas horas antes dos balaceras de
esas que son frecuentes en eeuu que
habían tenido un número de víctimas
importantísimo y que por primera vez
parecería que estaban dirigidas al menos
una de esas balaceras puntualmente a la
comunidad latinoamericana van dirigidas
entonces uruguay las autoridades
uruguayas señalan a todos sus ciudadanos
que si no es absolutamente necesario
viajar a eeuu lo hagan porque es un país
y lo que uruguay se dio el lujo de
nombrar creo una docena de ciudades en
eeuu que consideran totalmente y nombró
tres ciudades que son están entre las 20
más peligrosas del mundo sí igual no es
la primera vez que un país
latinoamericano hace unas cosas de estas
características ya lo había hecho brasil
con la la historia de la reciprocidad en
cuanto a la entrada en la visas y cuando
eeuu empezó a pedir visa y empezó a
pedir una caterva de papeles para poder
darle la visa a los brasileros los
brasileros pusieron esta esta tasa de
reciprocidad y les hacían pagar y lo
hacía al ciudadano americano haga esa
cola y los tenían cuatro horas sacándole
la abuelita de los deditos y haciéndole
exactamente lo mismo que pasa un
brasilero cuando va a eeuu de vacaciones
así que bueno es eso entonces fue está
interesante lo que está bloque está
pasando y todavía falta para las
elecciones entonces me imagino que habrá
otras elementos a destacar otras
novedades
volvamos entonces aquí a canadá estamos
en pleno verano en estos momentos se
está llevando a cabo el torneo de tenis
paloma es una especialista del tenis le
gusta muchísimo y existe algo muy
interesante también una una nota sobre
lo que está ocurriendo en dos torneos al
mismo tiempo que es el torneo es uno de
los torneos 1000 creo que se titula que
son los otros más importantes después de
los gran slam en importancia en dinero
en puntos y en todo el de montreal es el
de los varones el de toronto es el de
las mujeres y donde estamos para los
mejores pues estamos en que los
canadienses todos los canales
exceptuando las mujeres hay allí todavía
dos canadienses creo que bianca andrés q
y ya unas se fue la otra chica que era
una y entonces queda únicamente una
canadiense de dos varios que estuvieron
concursando de hecho hubo una
particularidad de este año porque tanto
los hombres como las mujeres
canadienses tuvieron que competir entre
sí hubo muchos partidos
canadienses y claro es lamentable pero
bueno de todas maneras hay que decir que
los canadienses y de quest ix son muy
jóvenes también se están siendo
generación empujando se están ubicando
en el mundo del tenis de una manera
extraordinaria la jovencita está de 16
años leí la firma de fernández ganó el
roland garros de francia sí
bueno que participó en toronto recibió
una invitación y por supuesto fue
eliminada era obvio ante la no me
acuerdo que el número del mundo pero que
está pintando muy bien tenemos aquí en
montreal en en los jóvenes torneo de
varones el último que quedaba era félix
oye alias alias y además ha sido la gran
esperanza del tenis está allí
exactamente ayer el 10 y cumplió 19 años
el 8 de agosto
y lo particular conmovido de feve el
mismo día que federer y lo particular
con félix es que es capaz de hacer unos
si le falta experiencia en algún momento
se le ve la falta de casa y bien todo
eso pero tiene muy buenos comentarios
por parte de los grandes y por qué puede
hacer movimientos y juegos de gran
universo algo así entonces entonces
pinta bien el liberamiento a nadie si
quiere tomarlo tener joven como olga
dijiste vos es bianca andrés es en
toronto es número 23 del mundo pero si
sigue jugando como juega pues va pronto
si lo que quiere decir es para la gente
que no sabe cuando jueguen jueguen el
campeonato en eeuu es en key biscayne
cuando juegan en en españa es el
príncipe de godó aquí en canadá se juega
en dos ciudades diferentes y se van
intercalando hombres y mujeres y las
copas habrá copa rogers los dos pero la
sede de las mujeres y de los hombres son
las dos ciudades que en realidad atraen
mucho tenis que son montreal y toronto y
en el caso de una vez
en el verano canadiense mucho tenis
también se viene el festival de toronto
del cine con nuevos premios una nota sí
al nuevo crearon un nuevo premio para un
director de que no específicamente de
qué se trata pero es es para la
trayectoria innovadora de algún director
de obra y este y este año lo gana un
director nuevos nuevos el andés
neozelandés y que hizo la película de la
serie de algo
entonces sí bueno iba a haber otros
otros años
bueno entonces siguiendo con el tema de
las vacaciones lo que me sorprendió un
poco ustedes tres tomaron un poquito de
vacaciones un corto y lo interesante es
que lo hicieron porque ve que tanto
leonardo como louis pues nos trajeron
fotos muy interesantes que sacaron
durante las vacas
vamos a conversar vamos a comenzar con
las fotos de luís tenemos 4 fotos
louis vamos a ver si nos puede encontrar
mostrar piedras las fotos vamos a
empezar por esa foto de qué se trata
bueno hay que aclarar que si se trata de
vacaciones son para ser bien modestas
son apenas unos minutos de auto y aquí
la perdiz es una localidad de la ribera
sur de montreal en el condado de
reposición es un condado
así se encuentra por ejemplo lo que
estamos viendo ahora que es un monolito
que resguarda a la primera vía férrea
eso es existió en canadá en qué año se
inauguró en el año 1803
la perdiz con lo que hoy es salsa un
servicio libre en un trayecto de 121
kilómetros de vía férrea lo que queda
listo
y mucho más en la pista así que digo es
decir tomo el caminito de la vía
probablemente pero en todo caso hacemos
esto recuerda este primer ferrocarril
que era un ferrocarril de carga que fue
impulsado entre otros por la empresa
bolsón
aunque la verdad es que nunca llegó a
transportar demasiado
y otra edificación también de la prédica
mí me llamó mucho la atención porque
dice que es una planta potabilizadora de
agua y cuando yo me acerqué y miré por
una de esas ventanas en esos gestos
audaces que no tienen cuando anda por
ahí vi que se trata de una casa
particular si se me llama mucho la
atención porque había un cartel es que
es pero tiene la tiene toda la pinta de
ser una casa particular pero es muy
probable que adentro haya oficinas yo no
me meto acá porque si no no estaría
secarse salud medicina iom inmobiliaria
adentro dije no acá vamos a molestar ahí
entonces me dice así en ciudad pero lo
cierto es que esta es cuando salió la
acción señora en button
[Aplausos]
la primera foto que hemos visto es un
museo de arqueología que se encuentra
también allí en a prairie en el condado
región que estamos viendo hoy nuevamente
y viene muy bien el dato porque estamos
en el mes de agosto que es el mes de la
arqueología
para planificar las cosas fotos de un
mes pero bueno
ahora vamos a ver las fotos que trajo
leonardo también por donde anduviste
leonard nosotros hicimos un viaje que
hay que hacerle una vez al año lo
hicimos
leonardo
fuimos hasta la calle en el mundo así es
el fin del mundo queremos el norte allá
en quebec a donde se acaba el mundo que
realmente se acaba
y ahí está vivo vimos casi casi como
cada capa de la tortuga el fin del mundo
así se llama eso es en el parque
nacional forillo en caspe sí así que es
un en este caso es una de las caminatas
bueno que viste una particularidad tiene
más de 40 faros en todas sus costas así
que ese es el que está justamente arriba
de el fin del mundo les dan en ellos es
exactamente dónde termina digamos la esa
parte de la tierra y está conectado
directamente al mar y eso es parte de
atlántico sobre una de las playitas y
está lleno de ensenada de esa manera
toda esa esa formación rocosa es súper
presente en esa zona de la
puede uno bañarse en esas aguas si tiene
uno la capacidad de sentir el frío sí y
nosotros hicimos 12 horas de auto porque
íbamos con una con una casa rodante
12 horas de auto desde desde montreal
exacto así que paseando por la costa del
norte dando un momento tendremos que
traer mapita para que vean dónde queda
porque es realmente interesante
así que vamos siguiendo el río san
lorenzo desemboca también podemos
desplazarnos hacia una transmisión desde
allí
más fotos porque estamos restringidos a
4 tengo 670 fotos
para mostrar
fueron 6 horas de caminata saca fotos
tanto para descansar un poquito y hace
fotos yo te tengo que mostrar otra zona
hay unos paisajes yo no sé por qué uno
siempre tiene que irse afuera habla de
ir afuera de vacaciones y acá y hay que
aprovechar el verano es cuando hay que
mirar lo que ve todo
las fotos de nueva escocia y vamos a ver
lo que es nueva escocia vida si alguna
vez el viaje este tan promocionado por
la empresa canadiense de trenes estrella
el viaje que hace de este a oeste
canadá que son trenes especiales con
vistas panorámicas
para ordenar
también puedes bajar en los pueblos y
dormir en el mar
bueno vamos ahora entonces como este
programa también cuenta con la
participación de los oyentes como
saludar antes a la gente que está
conectada con nosotros
gilberto martínez él dice saludos rs y
canadá desde nicaragua
gustavo lucas dice luis y leonardo
tienen que contar sobre los campings a
dónde fueron a los campings propuse
manfred echeverría dice saludos amigos
desde ecuador leonardo nicolás emanuel
rayman dice les estoy mirando desde san
ramón de la nueva orán provincia de
salta república argentina y luis
balderas saludos amigos de radio qhana
internacional canadá las américas desde
el puerto de san antonio de chile
gracias a todos por estar compartiendo
con nosotros este mediodía que bueno y
tenemos también mensajes de los oyentes
y se están acumulando así que vamos a ir
un poco con algunos de ellos entonces el
louis si quieres empezar si tengo un
mensaje que envió juan andrés sobre el
tema médico canadiense dice que la
diabetes tipo 2 es curable y él dice me
encantó lo que compartiste sobre todo lo
que el profesor en el instituto de
investigación clínica de montreal lo voy
a combinar con lo que estoy haciendo
si alguien está respondiendo pero no sé
exactamente aquí en el tema sí pero
bueno es el mensaje que nos hizo llegar
juan andrés salón tengo aquí un mensaje
con respecto a un reportaje de regreso
de la gripe h1n1 a canadá a muertes
inocentes y evitables y dice javier
gonzález nungaray con respecto a este
artículo publicado yo quiero comentar
que el virus de la influenza h1n1 no sé
si sea el mismo
ese nombre en el artículo y sí sí eso
causó muchos problemas de salud pública
en el año 2009 acá en méxico en niños
menores de 7 años me parece que fue
después pero si hace sin causa mucho
y en personas de la tercera edad
inclusive hasta el buen hasta un buen
número de muertes los organismos de
salud pública mexicanos han establecido
campañas de vacunación permanentes
principalmente en la época invernal que
es cuando más se desarrolla este virus
en niños y personas de la tercera edad y
además personas con pocas defensas un
abrazo para todos en el castor
cibernético en este 2019
javier gonzález nungaray y si hiciera el
mismo virus y era con respecto a las
vacunaciones y vacunar por ejemplo el
viaje año de cuando cuando brotó el
virus y todo el problema este de salud
pública en general que se habló hasta de
posible pandemia
yo iba a argentina del viaje no pero en
las autoridades argentinas como
estábamos en el norte había más casos
las autoridades argentinas recomendaban
vacunarse así que la familia de viajar
para poder viajar tranquilos digamos por
el día la necesidad de la la la la la
la autoridad aduanera pedía ese
documento para entrar contra aquella
prevención y es obligatorio hay que
hacerlo yo tengo un mensaje acá sobre
avance importante para mejorar la visión
de pacientes con glaucoma escribe eva
eva salaberría y dice hola a mi marido
tiene miopía necesitaría saber si acá en
la argentina se puede conseguir esa
medicación qué dosis administrarla y si
ya ha sido probada y aprobada muchas
gracias es un comentario de eba si igual
la miopía y el glaucoma son dos cosas
completamente diferentes
debe saberlo y acá tengo una en realidad
una pregunta si tengo una pregunta
acerca de la nueva aplicación y eres el
rey de la tecnología si está hablando de
mí le agradezco y si así le dice le
agradezco muchísimo que me diga esto en
realidad no me llevo bien
bueno entonces la pregunta s dice
cuadros legos los artículos directamente
en el sitio web puedo subrayar y buscar
la definición de las palabras es decir
que hay un diccionario que se pone en
marcha cada vez que pulso la palabra me
encanta esa función de que me ayuda a
ampliar mi con mi vocabulario lo he
intentado con la nueva aplicación pero
sin éxito sabe si es posible hacerlo con
la aplicación o no se puede puede ser
que tenga que activar que algo en la
configuración del iphone yo según lo que
yo tengo entendido ni siquiera en la
computadora lo que él tiene es algo que
ha puesto en su navegador que le permite
hacer eso el sitio internet no te
permite hacer eso no hay ningún elemento
que esté relacionado directamente el
sitio internet con un diccionario o algo
por él es la aplicación no en el sitio
en porque habla que lo puede hacer en el
sitio internet ya yo le explico que
probablemente su computadora tenga en su
diccionario se ha aplicado a al
navegador que google ha instalado eso
probablemente sea en 2
chrome que tiene la posibilidad como una
extensión si tiene para poder utilizarlo
como
digamos como diccionario ahora en la
aplicación no porque es digamos un
circuito mucho más cerrado la
información es es mucho más rara que sea
rápido ese tipo de funcionalidades si
uno les pone desde la página de internet
se haría mucho más pesado entonces
panelistas de ese tipo de complicaciones
no en cuanto a la navegabilidad del
sitio de la aplicación entonces no en el
caso de aplicación no no existe esta
funcionalidad ya vamos a estar hablando
sobre la aplicación en unos segundos
seguimos sobre un poco con los mensajes
mls si yo tengo un mensaje que nos envío
jairo millán sobre el tema podría canadá
aliarse con méxico y uruguay para
apaciguar la crisis en venezuela y jairo
millones lo escribe en francés pero lo
vamos a leer para vez intención es que
es un quebequense no lo sé pero para
beneficio de audiencia lo vamos a hablar
en español y sería magnífico la
tradición mediadora de canadá podría
contribuir a la solución de la crisis en
venezuela y agrega
es el camino muy bien excelente
excelente comentario paloma si canadá se
posiciona en el mundo por derechos lgtb
está ayudando a huir a chechenos de
rusia es el reportaje y franz y elena
rodríguez comenta hola mi nombre es
francis soy lesbiana llevo ocho años
huyendo por varios países con mi hijo de
12 años en un mes voy para canadá quiero
que por favor me ayuden allá en allá
soy de colombia ella era activista por
favor contacte me ayude no sé estoy en
en eeuu es bueno francine no podemos
ayudarla
en el sitio web y si alguien quiere
responderle pues es libre exactamente
hay además como mediadores y hay
muchísimas organizaciones en canadá
ayudan
[Música]
entonces muy bien
otro mensaje yo tengo que en realidad
una pregunta de pablo todo
toledo la mía en nuestro
fit de internet y dice que college
recomiendan para estudiar en montreal
depende que quiera estudiar hay dos
grandes universidades en francés y dos
grandes universidades en inglés
después coles efectivamente es viendo
que lo que uno quiere hacer y hay una
oferta grandísima así que otra cosa que
yo quiero mencionar es que estudiar en
canadá como extranjero sin un estatus de
residente o de ciudadano es muy caro es
mucho más caros sí pero la gente sabe es
carísimo es caro pero mucho más barato
es seguro especial es ahora algo la
universidad mcgill tiene un porcentaje
elevadísimo de estudiantes
norteamericanos el francés y una de las
razones es que los precios en las
universidades estadounidenses son muy
altos para el común
me acuerdo cuando lo estudiaba en la
universidad de montreal yo pagaba por
ejemplo no sé 300 dólares por año entre
decisión por sesión para la inscripción
y accesorios
extranjero pagaba 5.000 la diferencia
puede ser yo en la universidad miguel
cuando estudié allí al principio vine
con una beca y era 12 mil dólares por
sesión así puede ser ese 2 porque las
extranjeras 12 mil dólares en eeuu
porque sos extranjera vas a pagar 60 o
más probable en dólares la diferencia es
muy finas y enorme es muy grande y que
hay que decir que los que vienen a
estudiar afuera generalmente pues tienen
un nivel de adquisitivo mayor que el
común también de lo que tiene ahora
vamos y lo que aquí estuvimos hablando
vamos a ir a la aplicación de limpiar la
aplicación
ok entonces directamente el teléfono en
realidad estamos ahí en él
la tengo instalada y dice así en español
porque ustedes pueden bajar en realidad
cualquiera de las cinco lenguas en las
cuales trabajamos es decir las dos
lenguas oficiales francés inglés español
chino y árabe
si nosotros hacemos clic en la
aplicación esta es en realidad está un
poquito más abajo pero esto es
aproximadamente lo que se ve tenemos ahí
que no vemos porque está cortado arriba
en la pantalla pero tenemos categorías
en cartelera política sociedad de
inmigración y refugio si vamos pasando
se puede pasar con internet tecnología
economía están todas las grandes
categorías en las cuales está divido en
nuestro sitio internet
y la fácil navegación de los artículos
pueden irse al menú me encanta por le
dicen el menú de la hamburguesa son las
tres rayitas que están arriba que en la
pantalla no se ven pero ahí tiene los
formatos largos escenas de la vida y
nuestros programas en vídeos se hacen
clic en nuestros programas en vídeos
están podrán ver la emisión en directo
que ahora justamente está en la parte de
arriba así que no la vamos a ver pero
porque para una cuestión de
funcionalidad cuando salen mensajes para
que no hagan un desdoblamiento de la
imagen que estamos viendo se muestra
nada más que los mensajes entonces por
eso corta en la parte de arriba de la
pantalla así que bueno la recomendación
es bajen la aplicación sumamente fácil
de utilizar con muchísimas por ejemplo
lo que soy miope que no voy a realizar
lo que tiene que ver con mi presbicia yo
tengo todo en mis hombros entonces por
ejemplo
entramos en
en cartelera entró el sitio histórico y
no lo veo puedo ampliar la
sin sacarme los lentes eso para mí es
una bendición de las cosas entonces
tiene ventajas tiene muchas ventajas
guardarla después por ejemplo y abajo
tenemos la estrellita que se ve en la
parte de abajo a la derecha podemos
exportar y mandarle a alguien el
artículo que estamos leyendo en realidad
tiene un montón de funcionalidades súper
interesantes así que la recomendación
bajen y cómo hacen para bajarlo se van
hasta el sitio internet de radio gran
interna cional arriba a la derecha en la
columna de la derecha tienen el la
publicidad o no el icono hacen clic ahí
y está la posibilidad para bajada es muy
fácil trabajar las cosas muy bien
gracias a leonardo por esto y entonces
vamos a ir ahora a otro tema que tiene
que ver un poquito con las vacaciones
que estuvimos hablando porque este
reportaje que hizo paloma tiene unas
fotos fantásticas que es lo que me atrae
para hablar del tema pero para hablar
del tema hay que explicar el contexto de
este reportaje
esto se trata de una ciudad en nueva
escocia
se llama luna ember y que tuvo problemas
de olores muy fuertes y entonces se
inventaron como una especie de filtro
bio y qué pasó bueno lograron eliminar
los olores que era lo horroroso de esta
situación porque es una ciudad hay que
decirlo estamos viendo me viene la foto
eso es nueva escocia si no sabe cómo
huele
lo interesante es que esta ciudad fue
declarada patrimonio de la humanidad por
la unesco y es uno de los sitios
turísticos más populares de nueva
escocia entonces por lo tanto el olor
era muy preocupante porque la gente tuvo
que quedar ausente a la gente claro es
la gente tuvo que quedarse dentro de sus
casas por varios meses fue muy difícil
salir muy poco para lo más mínimo
necesita tico por un mes es el olor
sigo muchísimo en diferentes niveles no
entré intensidad muy fuerte y menos
intensidad pero al final lograron
aplicar una tecnología que es muy
antigua parece muy nuevo y muy novedoso
pero yo sí lo es pero es vieja se
comenzaron a utilizar los biofiltros más
lejos
claro entonces lo que hicieron es
aplicarlo a esto es una es una es un
filtro hecho con raíces de árboles
trituradas y se ve ahí lo vemos estas
son las raíces en las en la zona donde
estaba saliendo el aire el porque lo que
sucedía es que la planta de aguas
residuales de la ciudad estaba
expidiendo todos los olores nauseabundos
hacia el aire libre claro entonces o lío
horroroso circular había un problema en
el escape de la de esta planta de
residencia bueno entonces entonces
mientras aplicaron el filtro este que
funciona con animalitos que monago el
olor y yo lo que quiero ver son las
fotos de las casas yo quiero ver la foto
de las casas microbios no se pueden
verlos
queremos ver las casas
en sociedad es patrimonio de la unesco
por esas cosas por esas construcciones
maravillosas son consideradas de las
pocas construcciones de la época de la
época victoriana al que se conservan
casi intactas entonces hay cosas en el
collage unos agentes conservantes el
olor y la ves
y hay otra otra casa hay casas hay otra
casa ahí abajo que está preciosa
mira mira estas casas son hermosas y más
todavía más quién está aprendiendo muy
bien a hablar hablamos siempre mira esas
casas son preciosas son típicas de nueva
escocia saca exactamente en buenos es
por eso es bueno que se fuera el olor
porque imagínate la gente no va a poder
visitar esas maravillas
bueno entonces también había otro tema
que yo quería destacar esta semana
quiero vale al otro tema y es que
justamente estábamos mencionando que
este fin de semana es la marcha del
orgullo gay y así en montreal y pues la
semana pasada se hizo la gran marcha que
fue enorme en vancouver la gran marcha y
lo que yo quiero destacar simplemente
con esto es que se ve en primera plana
al primer ministro de canadá
participando en esta marcha junto con el
líder del nuevo partido democrático y la
lideresa
pero juntos caminando crudo a diferencia
de otros primeros ministros de su
antecesor inmediato en todo caso siempre
está presente la espera además fue el
primer primer ministro en participar
públicamente con su familia de ahí lo
vemos no tenga marcha del orgullo de lo
cual digo yo ayuda a vivir mejor en
democracia cuando un gobierno protege a
las minorías que esa es otra ese es otro
de los roles que tienen que jugar un
gobierno democrático y por eso me parece
importante señalarlo si no ya me parece
importante que él tenga también la
posibilidad de dejarle el lugar a los
líderes de los otros partidos para que
estén con él o sea esto es una cuestión
política hubo también gente que fíjate
las banderas de américa latina que
participaron también en esa marcha del
orgullo que mantilla que hablábamos de
todo es interesante también muy cortito
lo digo que yo me lo he cruzado en
alguna marcha trudeau participando y es
interesante ver el despliegue de
seguridad que tiene comparado con lo que
es por ejemplo el despliegue de
seguridad
eeuu obviamente tiene sus guardaespaldas
pero muy lejos es agresivo
bueno muy bien ya que el tiempo se nos
está yendo vamos a pasar ahora entonces
a los reportajes que nosotros destacamos
en la semana que eso también es un tema
que ese pues y súper interesante muy
bien voy a conversar con él comenzar con
luis laborda existe un tema que cuyo
digamos está teniendo cada vez más
actualidad en el mundo si tomamos en
cuenta que hay que defender el medio
ambiente y que uno de los grandes polio
como donantes son caminantes son por
supuesto los a los detractores en
general y entonces lo que vos estás así
existe un reportaje sobre como canadá
está promocionando está alentando la
venta a la compra de los ciudadanos de
autos eléctricos y la venta de inserción
del auto eléctrico en el mercado
canadiense se está dando mucho más lento
que en países de europa por ejemplo
también es obvio que el mercado es
distinto y las necesidades
desplazamientos son distintas pero poco
a poco el auto eléctrico va ganando
terreno en canadá sobre todo desde hace
tres meses
y de mayo último cuando el gobierno
federal introdujo un plan de promoción
de los autos eléctricos que otorga
rebajas y ventajas para los compradores
y esto ha hecho que en esos tres meses
de vigencia de este este plan se hayan
vendido 14 mil autos en seis euros
muchos efectivamente esos 14 mil autos
eléctricos van a permitir a rebajar 36
mil toneladas de emisiones contaminantes
a la atmósfera que multiplicadas por la
cantidad de autos vendidos y por la vida
útil de esos autos llevan esa cantidad
de ahorro de sustancias contaminantes no
arrojadas a la atmósfera a 460.000
toneladas y mejorar beneficios
financieros beneficios económicos se
pueden navegar de impuestos el valor de
automóvil se están hay planes como por
ejemplo la idea del principio de guardo
para instalar nuevos bornes de la
recarga eléctrica para permitir que sea
cada vez más pero los grandes centros
urbanos es decir tenemos que destacar y
lo sabemos
canadá es un territorio muy grande los
autos eléctricos todavía
alcanzado un grado de desarrollo como
para permitir los desplazamientos a
largas distancias pero no centros
urbanos están encontrando cada vez más y
están viendo cada vez más facilidades
para que puedan circular cada vez más
este tipo de vehículos que todavía son
un poco caros pero que el gobierno
federal y algunos planes provinciales
los hacen más accesibles y igualmente
vendría a ser nada es sobre todo la
provincia de québec que son los paraísos
de los autos eléctricos porque las rocas
lo que quiero decir es el otro día leí
un artículo que decía que en eeuu que se
venden muchísimos autos eléctricos hay
un grandes grandes zona de eeuu que la
energía eléctrica está hecha con carbón
o sea que es energías sucias con wang y
nantes entonces todavía cargando mi auto
con digamos a la larga estoy cargando
con carbón y yo del cielo del paraíso de
canadá porque hay un montón esta
mentalidad
la principal fuente es hidroeléctrica y
no hay contaminación extractor cesc
sería realmente un movimiento super
interesante hacer el esfuerzo y llegar a
ese tipo de vehículo porque ahí sí
estamos haciendo la diferencia se está
dando cada vez más en el transporte
público también en canadá ya lo podemos
ver los estos estos autobuses ya también
híbridos híbridos vamos ya que estás
hablando leonardo continuamos con voz
viajes calificados de acepta con google
qué significa eso más barato en realidad
no está cada una de las empresas está
tratando de ocupar un nicho donde ser
fuertes bien fuertes lo que está
haciendo google es a través de su
buscador y de dos o tres sitios que
tenía google viajes tenía google flight
los para los viajes en avión lo que hizo
fue meter todo no sólo y lograr
e integrar estas herramientas de reserva
de hoteles y vuelos para bueno
obviamente bajar los precios y tal y que
toda la gente pueda pasar por ahí
inclusive
ha hecho de su google mapas los que
tenemos en los teléfonos inteligentes la
posibilidad de hacer navegación en
realidad aumentada en tiempo real esto
qué significa uno apunta con el teléfono
con la camarita a través de google mapas
y uno ve lo que está viendo en el
teléfono es decir lo que apunta a la
cámara y los carteles y las indicaciones
se ven mucho más grandes y marca cosas
específicas que nosotros le damos
pedidas y entonces uno puede ir
navegando caminando un lugar que no
conoce y ver los carteles de los nombres
de las calles los edificios importantes
y todo eso aparece también tiene ganas
de ver ese tipo de detalles lo
interesante es que supuestamente a
partir de ayer estaba abierto a todo el
mundo ya había estado disponible para la
marca de google
específicamente en versión alpha durante
unos meses antes de lanzar ayer fue el
lanzamiento mundial pero parece que
canadá todavía no porque yo la traté de
bajar para mostrarles aquí adentro y no
funciona todavía así que lo normal pero
si la idea es súper interesante
la posibilidad es infinita cuando uno
tiene la aplicación y puede caminar y no
conoce ciudades de viajes seguimos en el
tema del medio ambiente sabes paloma nos
habla de una contribución ancestral y
una contribución ancestral de hecho es
un estudio que fue hecho dirigido por un
investigador canadiense que se hizo un
estudio que se hizo en canadá en
australia y en brasil para analizar la
degradación de los hábitats naturales
con presencia humana y como los
diferentes hábitos las zonas protegidas
o los hábitats manejados por grupos
indígenas o por grupos no indígenas cómo
se desenvolvían en cuanto a la
biodiversidad dentro de cada hábitat y
lo que pudieron comparar los que
obtuvieron ver estos investigadores
es que en los hábitats manejados por
grupos indígenas con sabiduría indígena
etcétera la biodiversidad era mayo
florece lograban mantener nuevamente
exactamente lograban mantener los
niveles de la biodiversidad mucho más
elevados que incluso en las zonas que
son consideradas áreas protegidas en las
diferentes regiones de su mar importante
porque hasta el momento se había visto
que las áreas protegidas que es la
principal manera de proteger zonas
extensas en donde la biodiversidad es
muy amplia eran en todos los países del
mundo y se creía que era la mejor manera
y ahora se dan cuenta que cuando una
comunidad indígena cuando una nación
indígena se ocupa de una tierra en
particular hace un uso con sus maneras y
costumbres tradicionales y con sus
necesidades las maneja siempre la
biodiversidad es mayor que incluso en
las áreas protegidas se puede decir que
es como un retorno de las primeras
exactamente entonces hablando mucho
también de la medicina
atrás de las primeras naciones y como
están descubriendo propiedades en
plantas que antes nadie las dejaban de
lado por prejuicios digamos lo que están
diciendo estos investigadores es los
diferentes organismos gubernamentales y
las diferentes incluso poblaciones
tienen que al aliarse con los grupos
indígenas y trabajar de la misma con las
mismas perspectivas y las nuevas
estrategias que son digamos ancestrales
y son sabidurías muy internas muy muy
importantes
yo tengo una pregunta para ustedes
alguna vez se les prendió una garrapata
pero si tuve en uno de los de los
campings en la ciudad de ontario no
porque él también estaba tirado en el
pasto jugando con él y cuando lo agarré
una forma bien clara al baño y en el
baño y carteles grandes y se tenga
cuidado con las garrapatas cuando vuelva
use la secadora para la ve bien y la
secadora para matar todo lo que pueda
llegar a ver y alojaba la ropa así que
yo quedé como hijo es ese es el tema que
yo destacó esta semana y seguimos con el
tema del medio ambiente porque
justamente debido al recalentamiento
global las garrapatas están apareciendo
en lugares inusitados donde nunca antes
aparecía se los ve m ahora se están en
las grandes ciudades de toronto o
vancouver montreal en todas las
provincias canadienses y hay alertas
justamente y lolo
lo difícil de todo esto es que es no es
nada fácil diagnosticar esta enfermedad
no sé si ustedes se acuerdan de la
cantante avril lavigne o de la cantante
thalía si ambas shakespeare huyeron al
borde de la muerte por haber sido mal
diagnosticadas se les diagnóstico y se
confunde mucho los síntomas con la
artritis reumatoide se confunde con la
fatiga crónica se la conoce como
fibromialgia entonces los médicos dan
los medicamentos erróneos y por esta
razón estas dos cantantes realmente
estuvieron al borde de la muerte hasta
que se dieron cuenta que no era eso lo
que tenía entonces esta enfermedad miren
la mancha que deja esta picadura siempre
es una buena forma de decirle a uno que
si hay que fijarse eso es importante eso
es importante y bueno la enfermedad es
causada por la bacteria que se llama
morelia que pasa del intestino de la
garrapata
a la saliva y de allí cuando pica a una
persona esa bacteria penetra por la piel
y va a la sangre de las personas durante
los tres primeros días después de haber
sido picado por una garrapata si se
dieron cuenta que es vayan al médico
porque si no puede haber consecuencias
es la garrapata de patas negras o la
peligrosa solamente sino pues estaríamos
todo el mundo estaría la garrapata bueno
acá tienen salud o iván realidad ni ná
macmaster martí dice cabe destacar que
mundialmente el desarrollo sustentable
de comunidades rurales casi siempre está
en manos de las mujeres sería
interesante considerar la perspectiva de
género en el equilibrio ecológico de las
comunidades indígenas ahí hay mucho que
aportar
seguro bueno entonces fue un placer
retornar ya estamos de vuelta y entonces
a todos nuestros oyentes la bajo la
voracidad infernal estás por
acompañarnos y la cita entonces es el
próximo viernes muchísimas gracias
[Música]
e